tax season is coming up and it may be
more stressful than usual and your
refund it may be delayed the irs
recently warned of major challenges
their words for taxpayers due to the
significant backlog of returns from last
year the agency also says it faces major
staff shortages our scott mcfarland has
more now on the growing pressure on the
irs no one's a fan there scott good
morning
hey tony good morning to you taxes are
due april 18th this year but the
question is are there enough tax
collectors here at the irs to promptly
handle what you submit and get your
refund check out the door
the 2022 tax season crunch has
officially begun filled with talk of
dollars deductions and delays lori reed
a small business owner from fairfax
virginia is already at wit's end that
uncertainty caused a little bit of a
headache for you it's a huge headache
until just days ago she was working to
remedy an issue with her 2019 taxes
trying to track down a refund check she
and her accountant say calls to reach an
irs agent for help often landed them on
hold for hours it's an enormous hassle
and i think when you own a small
business and you're trying to keep life
running you have this sort of burden
knowing that there's unfinished business
that's because this tax season the
numbers aren't adding up inside the irs
itself the agency is warning of severe
understaffing you're saying the agency
is operating with hundreds fewer
employees than it should or needs
thousands fewer employees than it needs
a wave of retirements and budget cuts
have hammered the irs a report by the
national taxpayer advocate reveals the
irs received 282 million phone calls
from taxpayers last year but was able to
answer only about 11 percent of them the
report adds the lucky ones who did get
through waited an average of 23 minutes
on hold the irs isn't going to be able
to answer as many of those calls as it
should be able to deputy assistant
treasury secretary natasha sarin says
the weights could grow even longer this
year as covid further limits the number
of agents available we know that that's
going to be hugely frustrating for
taxpayers
in a complex filing season in the middle
of a pandemic the irs is also still
working to dig out from a mountain of
other coveted complications and backlogs
early in the pandemic some of the tax
processing centers were closed entirely
which stopped the processing of some
returns in 2020 and they're trying to
catch up using outdated methods when a
taxpayer mails in a tax return the way
that that information is inputted from
the irs's perspective is someone
literally transcribes by hand the
information from that return into the
irs's systems that's not how any other
business in this country is operating
and that's not how the irs should be
operating either
there is legislation to boost irs
funding but here in washington irs
legislation often gets caught up in
political debate and gridlock so in the
meantime the agency says if you can set
up direct deposit for your taxes
file electronically and this year more
than ever file early
tony
scott thank you no one likes the irs but
you like at least something that the
government does with that money and
you're going to need it all right thank
you scott we appreciate